Let's go to your voicemails.
The voicemail number to call in anytime is
two one nine two David P we haven't heard
from the ag man for awhile.
The egg man doesn't like what's going on with
rush Limbaugh's presidential medal of freedom.
Take a listen.
Hey guys.
Um, for years and years, rush Limbaugh has
been a cancer on America, spreading lies,
misinformation, hatred, making really ignorant
people believe people stupid things and vote
for war monitoring people.
And now that you got cancer, you guys kind
of use or forget all that stuff.
No, we didn't.
You act like, Oh, he was stuck a big, you
know, influence on politics.
He was a horrible
yes,
please don't forget that either.
Scumbag and karma means he's dying from cancer,
which is why he is gay.
And he was a drug addict and he and he hated
drug addicts.
He hates himself and I'm good for him.
A too bad you got to put him on a pedestal.
I highly disagree with your opinion of that,
man.
Listen, I think the ag man misunderstood.
All we said was this guy was a big player
in radio, a force not for good and I wouldn't
wish cancer on anybody.
I take no pleasure in him having cancer.
I don't gloat about him having cancer.
As I said earlier, getting the presidential
medal of freedom is disgusting.
He shouldn't have gotten it.
It devalues the metal.
It was a public, uh, reality show stunt by
Donald Trump.
I don't know that we disagree.
Ag man.
Uh, it seems possible that maybe you misunderstood.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
Unfortunately, Donald Trump is getting some
of the best polling news of his presidency
and we're going to talk about why and what
it means.
Germany also has a new receipt law and uh,
it is leading to some very, very interesting,
maybe unintended consequences.
I want to talk about that.
Bernie Sanders has also pledged to legalize
cannabis in all
50 States on day one is president.
Could he do it is the question.
We will discuss all of those stories and more
on today's [inaudible], the David Pakman show@davidpakman.com
[inaudible].